[musique]
Artem Studinkov, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes numéro 2 de l'ambassade de
Russie. Vous êtes ministre conseiller.
Comment allez-vous ? Ça va, merci.
On vous reçoit pour faire une petite
update, une update de votre précédente
interview chez nous. Euh déjà, on
voudrait marquer le coup en ayant une
pensée appuyée pour l'équipage de 15
personnes qui s'est fait descendre
au-dessus de la Syrie. Est-ce que vous
pouvez nous détailler un peu ce problème
?
Tout a été dit déjà. H vous savez que 15
militaires russes ont péri suite
à l'incident tragique. Comme a dit notre
président, c en enchaînement
des des circonstances euh tragiques. Euh
l'avion a été abattu par euh
l'antimicile
la missile euh terre sol antiérien de
l'armée syrienne. Mais tout ça c'était
dans le contexte spécifique, c'était
dans la confusion totale liée avec
une attaque de l'aviation israélienne
contre certaines cibles euh sur le
territoire syrien. Voilà pourquoi cela
nous a permis de dire que
la responsabilité pour cette incident
tragique qui a coûté la vie à nos
soldats, à nos pilotes,
cette responsabilité appartient à la
partie israélienne qui n'a pas respecté
certains accords qui existent et qui euh
marchaient plutôt bien avant. cette
fois-ci euh ils nous ont prévenu 45
secondes avant le début de leur attaque.
Euh ce qui ne nous a pas permis de euh
évacuer notre avion euh pour qu'il
quitte la zone. En plus, on nous a
indiqué une autre zone de l'attaque. On
nous a dit que l'attaque sera effectuée
dans le nord de la Syrie tandis que
c'était plutôt dans la région est dans
la région de l'attaquier.
Donc voilà, comme résultat, nous avons
euh une bavure, une bavure
assez rare mais qui arrive de temps en
temps et surtout dans la situation où
plusieurs forces étrangères sont
présents dans la région. Et dans ce
contexte, je vous rappelle que seul les
forces russes et euh les forces iranien
se trouve euh en Syrie de façon
légitime, sur la base légitime,
conformément aux accords belatéraux qui
existent entre Moscou et Damas, entre
Damas et Teran. tous les autres acteurs
étrangers qui sont sur le sur le
territoire qui sont présents sous telle
ou telle forme sur le territoire syrien
euh l'ont fait sans aval ni de des
Nations- Unies ni du gouvernement
légitime de la Syrie. Et cette présence
massive euh des forces des différentes
forces militaires dans les airs et sur
le sol peut mener à ces incidents. Voilà
pourquoi nous avons fait nous avons
investi pas mal d'efforts pour créer des
lignes directes avec le commandement
américain pour la ligne de des
conflictions
pour éviter les incidents pareil des
escalades. Nous avons la même ligne avec
les Israéliens, mais cet incident, cette
tragédie démontre une nouvelle fois
combien c'est dangereux qu'un tant de
militaires, tant de d'avions de combat
se trouvent dans le même ciel ou en tout
cas dans le même dans la même région.
Donc pour résumer la situation,
vous aviez un avion de renseignement qui
vole avec une maximum une vitesse
maximum opérationnelle de 645 km/h. Un
avion qui a été fait aux alentours de
1968.
une soixantaine d'exemplaires. Donc
c'est un avion lourd avec un profil
d'elle pas du tout de chasse. Il était
en période d'atterrissage et un chasseur
euh
israélien qui est
qu chasseurs
quatre chasseurs israéliens sont fait
attraper par le le système antimissile
S200
et un des chasseurs ou les quatre
chasseurs se sont planqués sous le
signal thermique ou sous le signal radar
de votre avion.
Est-ce que Est-ce que c'est bien ça ?
Oui. Euh vous savez que nous avons reçu
la délégation israélienne qui a présenté
sa vision des choses. Nous avons reçu
cette délégation à Moscou parce que les
contacts avec nos partenaires israéliens
restent très denses. Nous les avons
reçus à Moscou. Nous les avons écouté
comment ça
euh
quelques jours après l'incident euh
parce que tout le monde comprend combien
cet incident est dangereux pour les
relations bilatérales, pour la stabilité
de la région, pour la sécurité en
général dans la région. Euh voilà
pourquoi euh les Israéliens nous ont
donné ces explications, les explications
qui ne nous ont pas satisfait. Euh nous
avons déclaré euh de façon officielle
que euh c'est leur responsabilité dans
toutes c histoires, même si c'est pas
comme dans ce cas avec l'avion russe
abattu par euh l'aviation turque euh
quand c'était une frappe directe ou
plutôt attaque directe contre notre
avion, contre notre chasseur bombardier.
Cette fois-ci c'est incident mais
incident qui est qui qui est le résultat
des activités de l'aviation israélienne
dans le ciel. C'est rien. Euh vous savez
que nous avons euh pris quelques mesures
euh pour euh renforcer la la sécurité de
nos troupes et de notre avion en Syrie
en décidant de fournir à l'armée
syrienne euh quelques euh
quelques complexes de S300.
Euh justement, c'est c'est euh arme
défensive et je le souligne, c'est une
arme qui euh que nous avons planifier de
fournir euh à la série, ça fait déjà un
très bon moment, mais on a arrêté cette
opération suite à la demande euh du côté
de la partie israélienne.
Mais aujourd'hui, dans ce nouveau
contexte, quand notre avion a été
abattu, quand nous avons perdu 15 vies
humaines,
cette opération plutôt cette livraison
sera effectuée.
Une question un peu plus personnelle, ça
fait pas vraiment très mal au cœur quand
une arme de confection russe abat un
avion russe ?
Euh
évidemment euh une partie de
responsabilité du point de vue
technique, du point de vue de la
préparation euh du personnel appartient
à la partie syrienne. Euh c'est évident,
mais euh je répète euh cet incident a eu
lieu uniquement à cause de la présence
de l'aviation israélienne dans le ciel,
à cause de cette attaque illégitime.
Absolument illégitime.
Voilà pourquoi c'est une tragédie énorme
et président
Bachar Al-Assad, il a écrit à président
Poutine, il a présenté toutes ses
condoléances. Je présume que les
militaires syriens ont tout expliqué à
nos militaires. C'est une tragédie. Ça
arrive. Vous savez que sur tous les
théâtres
des guerres actuelles, en Irak,
en Syrie également, mais surtout en Irak
par exemple, en Afghanistan surtout, il
y a tout le temps des bavures. On
bombarde les troupes alliées, on
bombarde les euh comment dirais-je les
civils
en les confondant avec les terroristes.
Ça se passe tout le temps en Syrie. pour
la première fois. une tragédie énorme,
mais euh je répète, même si il y avait
des erreurs du côté syrien,
disons les les acteurs de cet incident,
les les auteurs de cet incident, les
premiers auteurs de cet incident, ce
sont des pilotes israéliens qui euh ont
amené cette confusion totale
dans cette région concrète de la Syrie.
Vous avez vous avez euh c'est votre
premier cadre Friendly Fire la sur le
terrain syrien ou est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu ce type de de problème ? Je peux
pas vous donner euh l'information que
c'est une première c'est un premier cas
de Friendly Fire parce que bon pendant
la phase active de l'opération tout
était possible mais c'est un cas le plus
criant, le plus euh connu avec les les
résultats les plus tragiques.
Au niveau des transpondeurs, est-ce que
le système S300 aura une discrimination
plus fine sur
Tout à fait. C'est euh c'est un système
beaucoup plus sophistiqué euh de la
poente. Nous avons des systèmes encore
plus modernes, mais là c'est un système
euh je dirais cinq fois plus moderne que
S200.
Euh et en plus maintenant, je pense que
plusieurs mesures techniques et
militaires seront prises euh entre nous
et les Syriens, entre nous et les
Israéliens pour éviter la répétition des
cas pareils. Parce que je suis sûr et
certain que la partie israélien euh
n'était pas heureuse de euh de cet
incident. Ils ont exprimé leurs regrets,
leurs tristesses comme ils ont écrit euh
mais ils ne ils n'ont pas présenté leurs
excuses. Euh par contre euh les contacts
entre les militaires israéliens et
russes euh sont maintenus toujours. Je
pense que maintenant cette coordination,
j'espère bien en tout cas que cette
coordination euh sera plus plus
efficace. Euh et en même temps euh je
peux pas euh être tout à fait optimiste
parce que je comprends euh en tout cas
selon euh toutes les déclarations de nos
partenaires israéliens euh il paraît
qu'ils se proposent toujours de
d'effectuer leur
euh leurs frappes, leur euh ils vont
continuer à faire le maximum pour
endiguer euh le renforcement des
positions de l'Iran en Syrie, ce qui les
enquète surtout.
le
et j'ajoute j'ajoute que nous sommes
bien conscients euh de ces
préoccupations israéliennes et voilà
pourquoi nous avons fait des efforts
énormes pour retirer euh les unités euh
composées des miles des miliciens
proaniens ou des troupes Iraniens de la
frontière entre la Syrie euh et Israël
dans la région des Golanes. Hm, ils sont
partis, ils se trouvent actuellement à
120 km de cette zone-là, de cette
frontière-là, justement pour rassurer
nos partenaire israéliens. Donc, nous
comprenons euh tout ce contexte très
compliqué euh ce contexte régional et
voilà pourquoi nous faisons tout pour
éviter euh les malentendus, les
incidents tragiques et voilà, en
réponse, nous avons eu cette cette
tragédie avec notre avion.
Vous avez perdu combien d'hommes depuis
le commencement de la guerre ?
Euh plus d'une centaine. Disons euh à
peu près 130 personnes.
Je vous réponds tout de suite si c'est
beaucoup ou non. Évidemment, chaque vie
humaine n'a pas de prix et nous
déplorons la mort de chaque notre
militaire.
Mais tout en comprenant que nous avons
commencé cette opération au mois de
septembre 2015, donc ça fait déjà 3 ans.
Phantum pour 3 ans,
c'est beaucoup, c'est beaucoup, c'est
toujours beaucoup. Mais compte tenu la
les les les échelles de combat et
l'échelle de notre participation, c'est
un prix euh que nous payons, un prix
très lourd, mais ce n'est pas un prix
euh
énorme, énorme. Je répète, tragique, un
prix tragique. Euh plusieurs familles
ont perdu leur père, leurs frères, leurs
leurs enfants.
Mais c'est le prix que la Russie paye
pour contenir le terrorisme
international dans cette région du
monde.
Récemment, Vladimir Poutine a fait une
conférence de de presse en présentant le
nouvel arsenal russe
d'armes des des systèmes d'armes très
très perfectionnés.
C'était au mois de mars 2018. Oui.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez ajouter ?
Est-ce que vous étiez au courant de ce
type d'armement ? Est-ce que c'est un
armement défensif, offensif ? pourquoi
le présenter à ce moment-là ? Et
oui, euh nous sommes des diplomates,
nous sommes des hommes de paix. Donc
pour nous euh c'est une surprise comme
pour tous les autres euh observateurs
euh nationaux et internationaux pour
tous ceux qui ont entendu ce discours de
de président Poutine, mais nous
comprenons très bien que notre industrie
militaire ne s'arrête pas et nos
chercheurs dans le complexe
militaire et technique
travaille en se basant sur les anciennes
traditions
qui vient de l'époque soviétique. Nous
avons une très forte école technique et
d'ingéner dans ce domaine là, dans le
semaine de la défense nationale. Euh on
a perdu une décennie après la
désagrégation de l'Union soviétique.
Plusieurs recherches ont été arrêtées,
il y avait pas d'argent et cetera. Mais
petit à petit avec euh la reprise des
positions de la Russie dans le domaine
économique et politique, les travaux euh
ont repris et comme résultat, nous avons
euh ces quelques nouveaux systèmes
d'armement qui ont été présentés par le
président.
Comprenez-vous que pour nous, ce n'est
qu'une réponse
euh à la politique que nous considérons
comme assez hostile et parfois agressive
de certains de nos partenaires à la
garde de la Russie. La Russie reste
toujours
euh euh un pays le plus grand le plus
grand pays du monde avec son son immense
territoire, avec
ses plusieurs dizaines de voisins.
Partout où il y a des menaces, partout
il y a des défis de façon tout à fait
différente. Nous sommes obligés à penser
à notre sécurité. Nous sommes obligés à
dépenser de l'argent pour
pour assurer le n le niveau nécessaire
de la sécurité du pays. Et c'est fait.
En tout cas, la les dirigeants du pays,
le leadership du pays s'en occupe de
façon assez spectaculaire. Euh cela ne
va pas dire que euh évidemment euh
écoutez là, je je vais faire une petite
comment dirais-je euh une petite
déclaration. Euh nous sommes au début de
notre échange et je vais m'adresser à
tous ceux qui nous regardent. Euh je
vais vous dire une chose. Évidemment euh
je suis là euh à ma qualité officielle.
Je suis diplomate, je suis fonctionnaire
d'état euh tout en restant citoyen russe
avec ses propres convictions, avec ses
propres idées, mais je me présente comme
en fonctionnaire d'état, comme le numéro
2 de l'ambassade de Russie et voilà
pourquoi je vous présente ici notre
position officielle. Je vous parle de la
part de de Moscou en quelque sorte
peuple russe
du peuple russe du peuple en quelque
sorte du peuple russe mais surtout je
représente l'État russe et je vous
présente notre vision des choses qui
coïncide très souvent avec mes propres
visions. J'essaie d'être sincère avec
vous, mais si vous attendez que je veux
vous découvrir des choses tout à fait
inconnu inédites, il faut pas espérer
parce que je suis pas un libre
politologue qui peut s'exprimer, qui
peut vous donner uniquement ma propre
vision des choses. Non, il faut pas
attendre ça. Je suis là pour défendre
bec et ongle les positions et les
intérêts de mon pays. Finalement, c'est
ma professioni.
Donc je vous dis avec toute sincérité en
même temps que la Russie évidemment n'a
aucune
vision agressive du monde, n'a aucun n'a
aucun plan agressif par rapport à
son étranger proche euh malgré toutes
les allégations qui
euh qui qui qui sont connues. Mais je
vous donne un petit chiffre, le budget
militaire russe est comparable avec
celui de la France et 10 fois moins que
le budget militaire américain, 700
milliards de dollars. Chez nous, c'est
70 milliards de dollars. Donc les
chiffres sont incomparables.
La Russie a changé complètement par
rapport à la période de l'Union
soviétique. Nous n'avons aucun intention
de d'agresser qui que ce soit. Tout ce
que nous voulons, c'est de créer des
conditions favorables pour développer
notre pays, pour moderniser l'économie.
Je pense que j'ai dit déjà ces
choses-là, mais je ne peux que répéter,
surtout dans le contexte de ces
armements. Ces armements ont été
élaborés et présenté uniquement pour
montrer à tous nos partenaires étrangers
que nos capacités militaires, nos
capacités de défense sont assez
puissantes pour assurer l'indépendance
et l'intégrité territoriale de la
Fédération de Russie.
La Chine s'est fait sanctionner par les
États-Unis à la suite d'une vente
d'armes entre la Russie et la Chine.
Est-ce que ça va continuer ? Est-ce que
l'industrie de l'armement
euh l'industrie euh l'armement des
armements russes marche très bien. Euh
c'est euh
secteur très important pour notre
commerce extérieur.
Combien de pourcent ?
Euh
non, je ne peux pas pour ne pas vous
dire des bêtises, euh je ne vous je ne
veux pas donner les chiffres exacts,
mais je pense que une dizaine de pour en
tout cas nos clients sont assez
nombreux. Ils sont partout dans le
monde. Euh parmi eux, il y a les membres
de le temps comme la Turquie.
notre notre euh notre euh partenaire euh
commercial très important, c'est la
Chine, c'est Lande, euh plusieurs pays
arabes, euh plusieurs pays de l'Asie euh
de de l'Asie de Sud-Est. Euh donc euh ça
marche bien, mais nous comprenons que
euh certaines mesures
euh qui sont déjà qui euh qui sont déjà
prises par Washington et qui seront
prises dans quelques temps peut-être euh
ne va pas nous faciliter la vie, c'est
sûr. Mais on va se débrouiller. Que
faire ? D'abord, nous continuons à
moderniser notre propre armée euh qui,
comme je vous ai dit, n'a pas connu euh
un grand investissement euh pendant
plusieurs dizaines disons en tout cas
pendant une bonne dizaine d'années entre
91 et 2001. Maintenant, il faut un petit
peu euh reprendre les choses. Il faut
moderniser euh il faut changer certains
matériaux euh et technique spécial et
certains armements. Donc notre industrie
euh
notre complexe militaire militaire et
technique euh
a pas mal de de commandes euh pour
l'armée russe et pour les partenaires
étrangers. Mais on va on va aller on va
on va s'adapter. on va s'adapter
euh euh aux nouvelles conditions euh d à
certaines mesures prises par Washington.
Queles sont les mesures de rétorsion que
vous allez appliquer contre cet embargo
ou contre ces sanctions ?
Contre les sanctions contre les Chinois,
contre les sanctions contre la Russie.
Ah, contre la Russie. Mais ces sanctions
existent déjà et
certains de ces sanctions vont perdurer
parce que
j'espère bien que nous allons voir dans
quelques temps le progrès dans le
règlement de la crise ukrainienne dans
les régions de Dombas. Et euh
suite à ce règlement, je pense que
plusieurs sanctions de l'Union
européenne seront lavées. En tout cas,
c'est la position des Européens pour
nous. Non, euh là, je peux vous dire que
c'est pas un problème pour nous. Euh les
sanctions ne font pas objet des
échanges, des consultations, des pour
parler, des négociations avec nos
partenaires occidentaux. Nous avons dit
et nous avons nous avons répété à ma
entreprise que c'est pas la Russie qui
va euh évoquer ce sujet lors de nos euh
contacts, lors de nos dans le cadre de
notre dialogue. Euh ce sont des
Européens qui ont euh introduit ces
sanctions. Ce sont c'est à eux de
entamer des négociations sur la levée
des sanctions, la levée des
contresanctions russes. Nous n'allons
pas évoquer ce sujet. Nous sommes déjà
adaptés à ce nouveau régime pour nous et
nous pouvons vivre avec. Ça c'est une
chose. Mais au moment où nos partenaires
européens, nos partenaires américains,
nos partenaires australiens ou canadiens
euh seront prêts à euh à changer à
tourner la page et comment dirais-je à
reprendre la coopération normale, nous
serons prêts à discuter ce moment-là.
Par contre, il y a des sanctions qui
vont perdurer
peut-être pendant des décennies des
sanctions liées avec euh
avec la Crimée, avec la réunification de
la Crimée avec la Russie. euh la
réunification qui est considérée comme
annexion par certains de nos
partenaires. Là aussi, nous ne pouvons
que euh prendre note de cette position,
mais euh comme nous avons déjà aussi euh
indiqué plusieurs fois et très
clairement, pour nous, l'affaire est
close. la Crimée est revenue euh dans la
mère patrie et h
les sanctions qui sont lié avec la
Crimée, nous le comprenons très bien,
très probablement elles vont euh exister
pendant des années et des années. Euh
nous avons aussi des relations avec les
États-Unis, nous avons des relations
très compliquées. Aujourd'hui, il y a
des sanctions. Là aussi, mais qu'est-ce
que nous pourrons faire ? Nous nous
n'allons pas céder. Nous n'allons euh
nous allons euh adapter nous allons nous
adapter à ces nouvelles sanctions
américaines qui paraît-il doivent entrer
en vigueur h au mois de novembre.
Euh bon euh on va voir quel impact quel
effet ces sanctions auront sur notre
économie. Mais même avec des sanctions
existantes, même avec la conjoncture euh
internationale qui n'est pas très
favorable au développement, les taux de
croissance en Russie euh cette année euh
sont prévus au niveau de 1,5 %.
C'est pas beaucoup mais c'est une
croissance quand même. Et euh nous
allons continuer, nous allons euh
prendre toutes les mesures nécessaires
macroéconomique et microéconomique pour
adapter notre économie pour pour
trouver les solutions dans le contexte
des sanctions étrangères qui durent et
qui vont perdurer quelques temps encore.
J'ai été à Moscou récemment.
Et mon plus grand désarrois, c'est que
il y a plus de fromage français dans vos
commerces.
Mais il y a des fromages suisse par
exemple. Si vous vous avez en tout cas
vous avez remarqué que il y a plein de
fromages dans les magasins. Non, on peut
pas appeler ça du fromage. [grognement]
Comment
on peut pas appeler ça du fromage.
Ah non mais vous êtes trop français vous
êtes vous êtes trop sévère. Non non les
fromages on produit nous-même nous
produisons pas mal de fromages. Ils sont
différents. Il y a pas de tradition des
camemberamber en Russie. Par contre,
c'est en train de se faire d'ailleurs.
J'étais très étonné.
Oui. Euh il y a d'autres euh il y a il y
a des fermiers il y a des fermiers. Je
connaissais quelqu'un qui euh qui grâce
disons euh à leur partenariat avec euh
euh les fermiers français, les
spécialistes français ont euh réussi à
euh lancer la production de certains
fromages euh de brebis surtout et de
chèvre en Russie dans la région de
Crassodard. Euh si je comprends bien, le
la quantité de la production n'est pas
énorme, mais des précédents des
précédents existent. Par contre là là ne
peutons plaisanter évidemment euh
certains euh
certains de mes compatriotes souffrent
beaucoup sont comme et Coulomè euh mais
Rockfort mais euh h on peut citer les
fromages françaises pendant une dizaine
de minutes. Je m'arrête là. Mais oui,
évidemment, c'est pas
c'est quoi votre préféré ?
Euh Couombier, je pense. Couombier. Euh
mais euh en tout cas h [grognement] les
fromages h la choix des fromages euh euh
est assez spectaculaire. Il y a pas de
fromage français mais que faire ? C'est
un problème à la fois des consommateurs
russes et des producteurs français
et des sanctions.
Oui. Non non, je veux dire que les
sanctions qui ont frappé à la fois
quelqu'un amateur de la cuisine et de la
gastronomie française en Russie, mais
surtout il a frappé les producteurs
français qui sont privés de ce marché
russe. Voilà. Et nous savons que les
chiffres de perte ont été très
considérables
pour les producteurs de pommes, pour les
producteurs de fruits et légumes,
pour les Oui, pour l'agriculture en
général, pour l'agriculture française et
européenne.
On reviendra sur les sanctions, les
embargots et tout ça un peu plus tard.
Vous avez évoqué le la Crimée
qui à la suite d'un référendum
est retourné comme vous le dites dans la
mer patrie. En ce moment, il y a il y a
un grand sujet. Il y a la mère de de
Paris qui a fait citoyen d'honneur Oleg
Sensof.
On en parle sans filtre. Qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe
? Oui, Olex Sensof, hm, c'est un
cinéaste euh
on peut dire russe-Ukrainien parce que
pour nous c'est un ressortissant, c'est
un citoyen de la Fédération de Russie.
Euh lui, il se considère
comme euh citoyen de l'Ukraine. Euh
Alexov fait partie des gens qui n'ont
pas accepté le retour de la Crimée en
Russie.
Mais au lieu de choisir des voies
politiques pour manifester son
désaccord, son hostilité même à cette
décision qui a été comme vous avez dit
approuvée par la majorité écrasante des
habitants de la Crimé. Euh et là je peux
vous dire que je connais euh la
situation crimée parce que j'ai des
parents là-bas.
Euh donc lui, il a choisi une voix des
activités terroristes
pur, il s'agit d'un p terrorisme pur et
dur. il a créé un groupe. Euh, ils ont
organisé euh deux euh deux incendies
criminels en lançant les bouteilles, les
cocktails molotoves euh dans deux
édifices occupés par des organisations
prorusses. Dans une dans un cas, c'était
une organisation prusse. Dans un autre
cas, c'était tout simplement la
représentation locale de la partie la
Russie unifiée.
et il se préparait déjà une action plus
forte, une explosion du monument de
l'énine par exemple. Je pense que
c'était le monument de l'énin et à ce
moment-là, ils ont été arrêtés par
les services
spéciaux russes. Donc
je veux la euh comment la clarté absolue
dans cette affaire-là. Ole Sensof n'a
pas été arrêté pour ses activités euh
politiques. Il n'a pas été arrêté pour
ses activités en tant que cinéaste. Il
était arrêté pour pour des actes très
concrets qui ont déjà été perpétués et
pour la préparation des actes plus
solides, plus dangereux.
Oui, personne n'a pas euh ce faire, mais
c'est juste une heureuse coïncidence.
euh l'explosion qu'il préparait, c'était
déjà comme je comme je dis déjà, c'était
déjà une opération beaucoup plus euh
dangereuse. Et voilà pourquoi il a été
pénalisé sévèrement par la justice russe
lors d'un tribunal, lors la lors du
procès qui a eu lieu et euh
il est en prison, il est imprisonné. Il
il est emprisonné. et hm [gémissement]
euh il a déclaré euh la grève de femme
pour euh on va on va y venir.
Donc il a été condamné à 20 ans de
prison pour activités terroristes.
Euh Amnistie International qualifie le
processus euh de procès stalinien.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur
votre perception ? Non, je peux pas euh
je peux pas partager cette fion parce
que le processus euh le processinien,
c'est le système des tro quand la
décision a été prise sans avocat pendant
une vingtaine de minutes, trois
personnes euh jugées euh en condamné et
euh
effectivement, c'était une pratique
absolument horrible que nous condamnons
euh euh aujourd'hui
euh euh par tous les voies. euh notre
état. Mais euh Olex Sensov, elle a été
jugée conformément à la législation
russe. Oui, la législation qui concerne
euh qui traite les actes terroristes et
les activités terroristes est très
sévère. La peine était dure, je le
confirme, mais ça c'est déjà c'est une
question de comment dirais-je une
question de goût pour eux. C'est un
c'est un procès stellen pour nous. C'est
simple procès absolument légitime avec
avocat, avec un avocat, avec la
possibilité de défendre ses intérêts en
procès. Je sais pas si c'était en procès
ouvert ou non, mais en tout cas tout le
document euh
existe et peuvent être consultés et
Olexensov, il est en contact avec le
monde extérieur. Euh donc je ne peux que
manifester mon désaccord avec cette
perception de la part de l'Amnestie
Internationale. Quand
quand dans certains journaux, on peut
lire que le FSB a monté le dossier à
charge et à dessin. Euh
je peux pas commenter ça. Il y a une
décision et il y a une
[raclement de gorge] et il y a une le
juge a tranché
la justice a tranché et voilà
quand on objecte à la Russie que son son
système judiciaire n'est pas à la
pointe, qu'il y a de la corruption,
est-ce que c'est vrai ? C'est pas vrai ?
Est-ce qu'il y a des associations en
Russie qui s'occupent de ça ? Est-ce que
Il y a plein d'associations qui existent
en Russie ? Il y a plein d'asso qui
œuvrent pour respecter le droit des gens
condamnés, des gens qui se trouvent dans
les prisons. Et il y a il y a pas très
longtemps, les cadres vidéos
ont été diffusés dans l'internet qui
montrait les collaborateurs
d'un centre pénitentiaire russe dans le
nord de la Russie qui ont battu
quelqu'un, une personne euh une personne
qui purge sa peine dans ce centre
pénitentiaire. Euh comme résultat euh
plusieurs collaborateurs euh de ce
centre ont été arrêtés et c'est un
procès qui se prépare pour les jugés
pour leur acte. Ce qui veut dire que la
justice marche, la justice travaille et
tout ça c'était grâce à la position
active de certaines associations de la
défense des droits de l'homme. Donc ça
marche en Russie. Par contre euh vous
avez mentionné la corruption. Euh
je ne peux pas vous
je n'ai pas de évidemment euh la
corruption c'est un grand problème de la
Russie. C'est un grand défi. C'est un
grand menace reconnu au plus haut
niveau, reconnu par le président du
pays. Euh il y a des gouverneurs qui
sont arrêtés, il y a des généraux de la
milice de la police pardon qui sont
arrêtés. Il y a des gens très haut
placés. Hier euh le frère de
l'exprésident
h de la République de Daguestan a été
arrêté pour la participation dans les
activités criminelles. Donc on mène
cette lutte qui est très difficile. Vous
savez que lutter contre la corruption,
surtout quand la corruption représente
effectivement, je le confirme en
problème majeur, lutter contre contre la
corruption, c'est très difficile,
ça prend du temps.
Ça prend du temps, c'est difficile, ça
demande vraiment des efforts
considérables. Peut-être on peut faire
mieux et nous le comprenons. Mais par
contre en ce qui concerne le système
judiciaire et
pénitenre, il y a des gens qui sont
pénalisés, des gens qui sont issus de ce
système et qui sont aussi pénalisés pour
les cas de pour les cas de corruption.
Mais je vous donne un petit exemple. Il
y a pas très longtemps euh j'ai vu euh
euh les photos dans euh
euh d'un monsieur qui euh euh qui
[grognement] se trouve actuellement dans
le centre pétire pénitentiaire français
en condamné pour je sais pas quel euh
crime ou je sais pas quoi, mais
quelqu'un assez connu qui a été filmé ou
plutôt photographié avec un téléphone
portable tout en restant dans le prison.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ? Ça veut
dire que quelqu'un lui a apporté ce
téléphone portable. Je pense que pour
une petite somme en euros, ça se passe
aussi chez nous. C'est évident, ce
problème existe, mais euh globaliser ce
problème euh je ne le ferai pas parce
que la lutte, elle est très visible
parce que les personnes qui ont été
condamnées, arrêtées et condamnées pour
les actes de corruption, ce sont des
personnes parfois très haut placées.
Revenons, on reviendra sur la corruption
après. On va revenir sur Oleg Sensof,
137 jours de de greffe de la fin. Il
réclame la libération de 60 70 détenus
ukrainiens.
Ça va se résoudre comment ?
Écoutez, euh
nous tous nous pouvons réclamer quelque
chose. Lui, il a choisi cette foi-là,
cette fo cette cette foi de d'une gr de
f et il ne demande pas sa propre
libération. Ah,
c'est un acte fort.
C'est un acte fort. Oui, c'est un acte
fort. Euh et je répète que Lexensov est
en contact permanent avec ses amis, avec
ses parents, avec ses avocats, avec
certains représentants de la société
civile. Euh ces photos ont été publiées.
Euh je ne peux pas entrer dans les
détails médicaux euh de son état de
santé.
Est-ce qu'il est gavé artificiellement
ou pas ?
Non. Non non, il accepte de consommer
chaque jour une quantité euh
de l'eau minéralisée et voilà. Voilà.
Euh donc il est
euh comment dirais-je ? Il se trouve
surveillance euh euh du service médical
de ce centre pénitentiaire où il se
trouve. Euh il n'est pas euh forcé à
manger, je répète, il est soutenu par
voilà euh cette
il dit que il dit lui-même que l'équipe
médicale s'occupe bien de lui, qu'il est
dans une confirme il confirme que les
conditions médicales sont bonnes et il a
même refusé l'idée de se déplacer dans
un autre centre de dans un autre centre
pénitentiaire qui une idée qui a été
proposée par quelqu'un de ses amis. Donc
il a préféré de rester là où il se
trouve actuellement. Euh il est observé.
Euh
moi personnellement, j'espère bien
qu'elle arrête sa grve de fond parce que
bah on peut pas réclamer la libération
de 120 personnes. Chacun est arrêté et
condamné pour des actes tout à fait
différents. Euh et euh c'est la même
imaginez-vous que euh disons, vous savez
que dans les prisons françaises, il y a
des il y a certains représentants euh
mouvement séparatiste,
les basques, les corses,
je ne veux pas citer la région français.
Imaginez-voue que demain quelqu'un
déclare une grève de la fin et demande
la libération de touses ces personnes
qui est considéré pour lui comme
des des prisonniers politiques, comme
des otages
euh des autorités officielles et ils
réclament leur libération. Qu'est-ce que
sera quel sera le comportement ? Quelle
sera la réaction des autorités ? Je
pense pas qu'ils vont
accepter
de libérer tous ces gens-là.
Il y a des Russes emprisonnés en Ukraine
ou pas ? Euh si euh il y a des Russes
euh qui sont prisonnés en Ukraine et
c'est un sujet euh
des échanges entre nos deux pays euh
parce qu'il y a des Russes euh euh tout
simplement des criminels mais il y a des
Russes qui ont été arrêtés pour leur
participation euh dans les événements au
Dombas et mais chaque cas est examiné
séparement parce qu'il y a un problème
des euh des prisonniers de guerre et des
otages
des gens euh qui sont détenus dans le
Donbas et en Ukraine, son sujet des
négociations dans le cadre du groupe de
Minsk. Euh il y a des Russes qui ne font
pas partie de de de ces histoires là
comme Sensov ne fait pas partie euh de
ce problème qui est traité dans le cadre
de l'accord de Minsk. Mais il y a des
relations entre deux obmutsmenes russes
et ukrainiennes, tous les deux, toutes
les deux euh femmes euh qui sont en
contact euh qui traitent ces sujets et
euh ce sont des sujets euh qui font
partie de plusieurs euh questions qui
fâchent aujourd'hui euh entre KF Moscou.
On va on va changer un peu de sujet.
Votre ministre de l'énergie a déclaré
récemment
que le pic énergétique de la Russie
arriverait entre 2 et 3 ans.
Est-ce que la Russie se prépare à une
transition énergétique ? Est-ce que la
Russie redoute le fait que son budget ne
pourra plus être à l'équilibre grâce à
sa rente énergétique ?
Il faut dire que aujourd'hui notre
budget euh dépend euh beaucoup de ces
rentes énergétiques, mais pas comme il y
a 10 ans par exemple. Aujourd'hui, euh
ça fait moins de 30 % à ma connaissance.
À ma connaissance, quand le baril de
pétrole est en dessous les 54 dollars,
votre budget n'est plus à l'équilibre.
Euh oui, mais ce temps est passé.
Aujourd'hui, c'est 82
dol de l'AR pour baril et certains
certains pronostics, ça va euh ça va
monter jusqu'à 100 dollars. Mais ça ne
change notre problème à nous. Nous
devons nous sommes condamnés à
diversifier notre économie. C'est un
défi majeur devant les dirigeants de la
Russie et devant notre économie
nationale. Et les sanctions nous ont
bien montré qu'il faut activiser le
travail dans ce domaine-là. Il faut
réindustrialiser
euh la Russie, il faut moderniser
davantage l'économie, il faut développer
le secteur agric de l'agriculture, il
faut développer le secteur énergétique
justement pour euh pour et tout tout ce
qui est lié avec l'économie verte euh
est vu avec beaucoup
avec beaucoup d'intérêt par les Russes,
par
le gouvernement. Hm. Oui, pour l'instant
nous sommes pas des champions dans ce
domaine-là et euh il y a pas mal de
choses à faire. Euh et nous comprenons
très bien que euh le défi est énorme.
Nous le comprenons et euh nous disons
nous nous nous entreprenons certaines
mesures mais il faut faire mieux.
Pourquoi le pourquoi le défi est énorme
?
pas parce que la Russie est en pays euh
énorme et développer euh une vraie
économie euh verte, une vraie économie
écologique et surtout euh diversifier
l'économie euh russe après euh tous ces
20 ans euh après la disposition de
l'Union Soviétique, quand une grande
partie de l'industrie a été tout
simplement détruite. C'est une sacrée
tâche qui démande pas mal de financement
et pas mal d'efforts. Voilà pourquoi
nous sommes réalistes. comprenons que
c'est une tâche très difficile.
Le PIB russe, c'est combien ?
Euh PIB russe PB
russe euh
je ne veux pas vous dire des bêtises, je
veux pas donner cette chiffre là. Je
vous promets de fournir ce chiffre
euh la prochaine fois.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire du
pic énergétique ? Qu'est-ce que vous
connaissez de cette notion de PIC oil ?
Est-ce que ça vous parle vous producteur
de pétrole ?
H donnez-moi quelques précisions.
Le pic de Uber, la
cette courbe en cloche
après le maximum de production qui
décroit qui décroit qui décroit. Est-ce
que vous êtes sensibilisé à ce type de
Oui. Euh mais euh écoutez, si je
comprends bien, c'est un problème qui
est lié à la fois avec le niveau euh
comment dirais-je euh euh avec la
modernité euh
de l'industrie énergétique et en même
temps avec les ressources que nous avons
et
qui peuvent être épuisées à un moment
donné. Donc pour l'instant le moment euh
n'est pas venu, nos ressources restent
toujours euh très considérables. En
plus, avec ces changements climatiques,
nouvelles options s'ouvre dans ce
domaine dans l'extrême euh nord-russe.
Euh mais euh technologique
technologiquement du point de vue de la
technologie, il faut toujours moderniser
ce domaine-là. Et là, les sanctions euh
renforce euh rend les défis encore plus
euh euh
compliqué pour nous. Euh mais nous
essayons de trouver des solutions. Nous
entretenons, nous nous essayons
d'élargir le nombre de nos partenaires
technologiques. Euh nous travaillons
beaucoup avec les Chinois. Euh nous
travaillons beaucoup avec d'autres
partenaires euh y compris occidentaux.
Euh mais c'est un des défis. Euh c'est
les c'est les occidentaux qui vous ont
poussé dans les bras des Chinois quand
on voit si Jing Ping
se faire un petit sandwich de caviare
avec Vladimir Poutine,
on peut le dire en quelque sorte parce
que nous avons après 2014
après l'introduction de ces sanctions,
après cette attaque y compris médiatique
contre la Russie, on a bien compris
qu'il faut mettre les œufs dans le dans
les différents paniers et notre aigle
bicéfhale, il regarde à la fois à l'est,
vers l'est et vers l'ouest. Mais c'est
surtout les changements économiques qui
se passent aujourd'hui en ce moment dans
le monde. nous font euh prendre des
décisions, nous font euh faire nos choix
euh ou plutôt euh
nous font évaluer un petit peu notre
ligne parce que non parce que je veux je
veux expliquer aujourd'hui
c'est dans l'Asie de Sud-Est euh où se
trouve le nerf de l'économie où euh se
déplace le centre de la vie économique
paraît-il. En tout cas, on dit
qu'aujourd'hui l'économie chinoise c'est
la 2e économie mondiale, demain
première. Nous le comprenons. Nous
comprenons que c'est dans nos intérêts
de participer dans la réalisation de ce
projet pharaonique
de nouvelles voix de soi euh qui est
planifié, proposé par
la Chine au monde entier, je peux dire
en tout cas à une grande partie des pays
asiatiques et européens. Nous comprenons
que cette foi va passer par la Russie et
nous comprenons que nous devons profiter
de cette
de cette opportunité pour renforcer nos
liens économiques avec ce géant
économique, la Chine, pour renforcer nos
liens politiques et pour renforcer nos
propres positions économiques
en acteur important dans les relations
entre l'Europe et la Chine. Mais en même
temps,
le rapprochement que vous observez
aujourd'hui dans les relations entre la
Chine et la Russie est lié non seulement
avec
l'économie et les intérêts financiers,
économiques, nous partageons avec les
choix les Chinois la même vision du
monde. Nous constatons avec eux que le
monde chaque jour devient plus
polycentrique qu'hier, que les temps
d'une seule superpuissance ou de deux
superpuissances, ces temps sont révol
les Chinois partagent notre analyse. Il
comprend que aujourd'hui il faut créer
un nouveau ordre politique, un nouveau
ordre ordre mondial basé sur le respect
de la droit internationale, basé sur le
respect du rôle principal de l'ONU, basé
sur le respect mutuel et des intérêts
des uns et des autres et de non du
principe de non en gérance dans les
affaires euh des pays. Donc notre
partenariat avec la Chine est très
profond. Il est basé sur plusieurs
plusieurs plusieurs aspects. La
frontière commune très longue, les
affinités culturel malgré la différence
mais il y a des traditions depuis
l'époque soviétique et même avant. Euh
les intérêts euh économiques, les
intérêts dans le domaine sécuritaire.
Voilà. Donc notre rapprochement avec la
Chine porte un caractère très profonde
et basé sur plusieurs plusieurs
plusieurs facteurs.
Vous avez pas fait vous avez pas peur de
vous faire manger ensuite par les
Chinois ? [raclement de gorge]
Oui, c'est une théorie très connue. Euh
je peux vous confirmer que dans les
régions limitrophes, il y a 6000 russes
et 120 euh pardon 6 millions russes et
120 millions des Chinois. Mais euh
écoutez, l'impérialisme
ne fait pas partie de la tradition
chinoise. La Chine était envahie, mais
Chine n'envahissait pas euh
n'envahissait jamais euh les
territoires. Euh si vous prenez
l'histoire millénaire, peut-être à
l'époque les les les royaumes euh avant
Jésus-Christ ou après peut-être il y
avait des guerres, il y avait des
accréditions à l'intérieur de la Chine
actuelle. Mais depuis un moment, la
Chine n'a pas manifesté
des pratiques agressives. La Chine a ses
intérêts, la Chine
veut respecter ses intérêts dans
certains régions, y compris dans la mer
euh euh
mer de Chine.
Dans la mer de Chine. Euh en ce qui
concerne la Russie et euh en en ce qui
concerne la Russie et la Chine,
euh nous euh euh nous sommes persuadés
que nos intérêts mutuels sont tels que
euh
nous n'avons rien à craindre.
Évidemment, je peux pas jeter un coup
d'œil dans 100 ans. Qu'est-ce que va
nous attendre ? Mais aujourd'hui, les
liens sont si profonds, les liens
personnels sont si forts.
Je ne veux pas parler de l'amitié parce
que l'amitié c'est une chose très
relative mais il y a des intérêts et
comme je vous ai dit, il y a des
intérêts politiques, économiques,
militaire, sécuritaire, culturel.
En ce qui concerne la situation dans la
mer de Chine, vous voulez poser la
question euh bon là je peux dire que
est-ce que c'est le respect du droit
international ? Est-ce que c'est une
projection ? parce que
évidemment nous sommes pour les
solutions qui seront euh le résultat des
compromis. Nous sommes pour euh pour les
négociations. Nous espérons que tous les
acteurs intern qui sont dans la région
mais qui sont vraiment dans la région
euh ils vont trouver les solutions
pacifiques et négociées. Par contre nous
nous pensons que l'ingérance brutale et
là je parle évidemment
des États-Unis
euh ne peut que compliquer les choses
dans cette zone là de l'océan Pacifique.
Mais nous sommes pour la voie négociée,
nous sommes pour les pour parler. Nous
savons que les Chinois tout en défendant
leur position, ils savent négocier, ils
peuvent être flexibles.
Mais il faut parler, il faut se parler.
La Russie et l'Afrique,
on voit beaucoup de Russes en Afrique
maintenant. Non, qu'est-ce qui se passe
? Bah, il faut dire que le les Russes ne
quittaient jamais l'Afrique. L'Afrique
depuis la libération depuis des années
60 60, depuis la libération de
l'Afrique, depuis la création de
plusieurs États indépendants en Afrique,
euh l'Union soviétique était présent
dans plusieurs pays africains. il a
investi beaucoup dans le renforcement de
leur indépendance, euh dans le
développement de leur économie, dans le
dans leur dans dans les domaines. On a
investi énormément dans le domaine de
l'éducation, de la santé, de
l'industrie. Euh mais évidemment compte
tenu que le monde était divisé
entre deux camps, il y avait des pays
africains où euh c'était l'Union
soviétique qui régnait en quelque sorte.
dans les autres pays, c'était
l'Occident, la France, euh la
Grande-Bretagne, les États-Unis qui
étaient plus présents, plus euh plus
actif. Aujourd'hui, il n'y a pas de des
raisons idéologiques. Aujourd'hui, nous
avons des intérêts économiques et
politique. Nous avons euh en grand
intérêt de profiter de ce liens qui ont
été
tissés pendant pendant les années
soviétiques.
avec les universités, avec les échanges,
avec plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'étudiants africains qui ont passé par
les universités soviétiques, qui ont été
formés à l'Union soviétique, qui
peut-être on ont oublié déjà la langue
russe, mais qui ont gardé de très bons
souvenirs euh
concernant leur séjour parfois très long
à l'Union soviétique. Donc, qu'est-ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui ? Aujourd'hui,
avec le renforcement de nos positions,
le renforcement naturel de nos positions
économique et politique, nous devenons
plus visible dans certains pays
africains.
hommes d'affaires qui représentent des
grands concernes, des grands compagnies
veulent
explorer les terres africaines, veulent
profiter de ses richesses tout en
respectant évidemment les intérêts des
nations et des pays. Euh mais je veux
dire tout simplement que nous avons déjà
des structures non étatiques qui veulent
venir en Afrique, qui veulent travailler
avec les Africains. Il y a des contacts
comptenu qu'il n'y a pas de des comment
dirais-je des
des problèmes idéologique. Aujourd'hui,
toute l'Afrique est ouvert à la
coopération. Il n'y a pas des zones des
chasses gardées des occidentaux et des
Russes. Tout le monde est présent
partout. Euh donc voilà hein, il y a des
Chinois. Mais il y a des Chinois, c'est
un autre facteur.
Il y a des militaires qui en Afrique. Je
p je je pense que votre question est
liée avec un seul pays africain, avec la
République centrafricaine.
Voilà, la République centrafricaine euh
un pays qui souffre depuis des décennies
déjà d'une instabilité absolue.
Cette ce pays africain profite de
plusieurs soutiens euh de l'Union
africain, de l'ONU et de la Russie qui a
euh qui accorde son aide militaire et
technique strictement
dans le respect de la législation
internationale, en coordination avec les
Nations- Unies, en coordination avec
l'Union africaine. ce que nous faisons,
nous augmentons les capacités des forces
gouvernementales
euh qui ont besoin d'être formé, qui ont
besoin d'être armés pour euh contenir
les menaces terroristes y compris, pour
maîtriser la situation de l'endomène de
sécurité et nous les aidons.
C'est tout ce que je peux vous dire.
C'est c'est c'est c'est vraiment
ces activités sont très transparentes et
je répète se font en coordination avec
les Nations- Unies.
Alors question d'Internet, que
pensent-t-il de la décision de Trump de
se retirer du Conseil des droits de
l'homme et de ne plus reconnaître
l'autorité de la Cour pénale
internationale ?
Bon euh
ces décisions s'inscrivent euh
parfaitement bien dans cette ligne euh
d'isolation et d'hilatéalisme.
Je vous ouvre une parenthèse si vous me
permettez. Oui,
la Russie reconnaît le tribunal de la
euh nous ne nous ne sommes pas membres
euh de la Cour pénale internationale
pour nos propres raisons, mais nous
sommes des membres activons
que déplorer le départ des Américains.
Cela veut dire que ils se sentent pas
très bien là où ils sont obligés de
défendre ce position. Là, ils sont euh
là où ils sont obligés de ripo euh de
s'expliquer parce que euh c'est pas
uniquement les États-Unis qui euh qui
accusent euh euh d'autres partenaires
internationaux pour tel ou tel euh euh
comment dirais-je non respect euh des
droits de l'homme. Mais les États-Unis
sont aussi très critiqués par la
communauté nationale et par certains
pays. Donc il il paraît qu'ils se sent
pas très bien dans ce cadre-là. Ils ont
décidé de partir. C'est une décision
déplorable. Je répète poursuivre les
juges qui s'intéresserait de trop près
des ressortissants.
Là, vous parlez là, vous parlez de la
cour pénale internationale. Ça c'est
leur décision. Je peux pas commenter la
décision souveraine américaine, c'est
leur décision. C'est au juristes de
traiter cette affaire si c'est comment
dire comment comment ça s'inscrit dans
le droit international. Mais je peux en
tout cas vous dire que euh le problème
euh euh
de la justice américaine euh qui est qui
est très active euh
à l'extérieur de ces frontières,
à l'extérieur de ces frontières, c'est
un problème euh très connu et c'est un
problème qui touche concrètement les
Européens, surtout maintenant quand les
États-Unis ont déclaré également dans le
contexte de la même ligne de Donald
Trump de quitter l'ord avec l'Iran,
l'accord de 2015 sur le programme
nucléaire iranien. Vous savez que
désormais ou plutôt surtout après le 5
novembre euh toute compagnie euh
étranger y compris européenne qui a des
affaires commerciales ou tout simplement
en partenariat économique avec les
grands peut être pénalisé très
sévèrement par la justice
extraterritoriale américaine.
Est-ce que Est-ce que
c'est à vous de me dire si vous acceptez
cette idée, cette pratique ou non. une
mais mais là mais là, j'ai mentionné ce
problème euh en ce qui concerne euh la
Cour internationale euh la Cour pénale
internationale, je répète, c'est une
décision américaine et euh c'est aux
experts de dire s'ils peuvent euh
poursuivre les juges de ce de ce
tribunal ou non. vraiment c'est un
aspect juridique. Je peux pas commenter
ça et euh
j'ai à euh j'ai à reconnaître que la
Russie ne fait pas partie de la Cour
pénale internationale. Et en ce qui
concerne la Cour euh la la commission de
l'ONU pour les droits de l'homme, là je
vous ai dit quelques mots.
Euh on va vous donner le choix. On parle
un peu écologie, on parle un peu
ressources. Est-ce qu'on parle un peu
d'effondrement de collapsologie ? En
France, en ce moment euh il y a Nicolas
Hullot, notre feu feu, notre ministre de
l'écologie qui n'est pas mort mais qui a
démissionné,
qui est parti Oui.
a parlé avec le premier ministre,
monsieur Philippe, d'effondrement,
d'épuisement des ressources. Est-ce que
en Russie c'est un sujet qui vous
préoccupe ? Est-ce que le gouvernement
russe euh a eu vent de de cette théorie
? Euh président Poutine est venu à Paris
pour assister aux travaux euh du sommet
sur le climat euh qui a été organisé par
la partie française, ce qui démontre
déjà euh combien nous sommes attachés à
la cause écologique.
Nous avons signé euh l'accord de Paris.
Euh nous soutenons euh la lutte pour
l'écologie. Nous comprenons que
déjà aujourd'hui, il faut réfléchir
comment le monde, comment la communauté
nationale
doit agir pour éviter cet affrontement.
Nous comprenons que la menace existe,
nous comprenons que le changement
climatique c'est une réalité.
Il y a différentes écoles. Il y a ceux
qui disent que euh c'est effectivement
c'est le résultat des activités
humaines, des activités industrielles.
Les autres prétendent que c'est plutôt
euh le cours naturel des choses. C'est
la la c'est la nature qui connaît des
cycles et aujourd'hui c'est le cycle de
réchauffement euh qui est arrivé.
[grognement] Mais dans toutes ces
choses, nous comprenons que le problème
est énorme. Euh nous le ressentons en
Russie. Les problèmes écologiques en
Russie sont très très euh très
importantes parmi d'autres problèmes.
Euh
il y a des régions qui souffrent plus,
il y a des régions qui sont euh en en
sécurité écologique plus élevée,
mais euh là aussi, il faut donner des
réponses collectives, mais des réponses
très bien élaborées, euh des réponses
qui respectent les intérêts nationaux.
Euh la Russie n'est pas le premier
pouleur du monde. Très loin. Nous sommes
très loin à cause de certains comment
dirais-je baisse.
C'est qui le premier ?
Euh ben je pense que c'est les
États-Unis. Je pense que les États-Unis
et la Chine luttent pour la première
place dans ce domaineel. Mais la Russie
comme tous les pays industriels
contribue à son tour. Mais nous ne
sommes pas les pollueurs les plus
importants. Mais nous comprenons que
nous pouvons souffrir de cette
pollution. nous pourrons souffrir de ce
rochement climatique. Voilà pourquoi euh
nous sommes très actifs dans ce domaine.
Et là euh par exemple non nos approches
avec nos partenaires français euh
se concite souvent même si il y a des
nuances, il y a des euh il y a des des
différences dans les dans les vision
dans l'analyse, mais euh je vous
confirme que c'est un problème très
important. C'est c'est un problème
global. Quand nous parlons euh de la
multipolarité euh du monde
polycentrique, nous avons dans la tête
également le problème écologique parce
que nous comprenons que là, c'est un
problème euh qui ne peut pas être géré
que par toute la communauté nationale.
Mais tout simplement, il faut élaborer
les méthodes, les pratiques ensemble
dans le cadre des formats internationaux
qui qui existent. Il faut travailler
ensemble.
Il y a un projet russe de centrale
nucléaire flottante.
C'est écologique ? C'est pas écologique
? Est-ce que le risque nucléaire vous
l'anticipez ? H
en principe l'énergie atomique euh
s'inscrit euh dans l'économie
écologique. Euh il faut évidemment
assurer la sécurité des stations
nucléaires, mais sachez que après la
tragédie de Ternobyl,
euh nous avons beaucoup investi dans ce
domaine là pour euh vraiment rendre euh
nos centrales nucléaires les plus sûres
du monde.
on fait beaucoup dans ce domaine là.
Notre compagnie nationale
Ross Atom, c'est un acteur important sur
la scène internationale qui coopère avec
euh la France, qui coopère dans les pays
tiers. Euh c'est un acteur très
important.
Euh, on a investi beaucoup justement
dans les nouvelles technologies, dans la
sécurité des stations nucléaires. On
tire des laissons après chaque incident
qui se passe même quelque part ailleurs,
par exemple après ce qui s'est passé euh
au Japon,
Fukushima.
À Fukushima, nous sommes très vigilants.
Euh nous sommes très conscients que
c'est bénéfique pour la pour l'humanité,
l'énergie atomique, mais ça peut-être
dangereux. Donc, il faut trouver un
équilibre. En tout cas, nous nous
proposons de développer euh
ce secteur euh de notre système
énergétique.
Vous vous en êtes où avec euh ce qu'on
appelle ce ce recyclage des combustibles
?
Ouais.
Ça vous avez
nous faisons partie euh il paraît qu'il
y a quatre pays euh de cycle nucléaire
euh absolu. La Russie fait partie de ces
quatre pays. Donc oui, nous maîtrisons
tout ce qui existe dans ce domaineel.
Quand on voit des des Japonais installer
une centrale nucléaire sur une faille
sismique, est-ce que la Russie
s'inquiète ?
Est-ce que la Russie pouvait donner des
conseils ?
Euh la Russie euh a son expertise qui
est une très ancien tradition. Nous
sommes prêts à donner des conseils. Euh
nous sommes prêts à construire des
centrales nucléaires à l'étranger, ce
que nous faisons aujourd'hui parce que
il faut dire que Rossatom c'est un des
sociétés euh qui fait partie qui qui
appartient aux sociétés les plus
développées, les plus puissants de la
Russie. euh il a connu beaucoup de
succès euh à l'extérieur du pays. Et
quand on parle par exemple de notre euh
balance économique, commerce extérieur,
les services euh et ce qui produit notre
industrie nucléaire représente vraiment
un morceau très important
euh euh voilà de dans ce secteur là.
Est-ce que vous est-ce que vous avez des
des associations du type Greenpeace qui
remettent en question votre
Il y a des associations écologiques
certainement ils ne sont pas si
puissants que en Occident mais nous
avons notre propre Greenpeace russe si
je me trompe pas. Euh non, les
écologistes euh sont présents sur le
terrain politique euh russes, mais il
est à reconnaître cette tradition, vous
comprenez, existe depuis 20 ans, 20 25
ans, depuis 91, depuis la disparition de
l'Union soviétique. Donc euh leurs
positions euh ne sont pas si fortes, si
euh puissantes qu'en France et dans
certains d'autres pays européens, mais
euh nous avons nos propres ver qui pour
l'instant euh nous ne sommes pas entrés
sur les chiquier politiques, ne
participent pas aux Non, ils ont
participé aux élections euh il y a
quelques temps, mais pour l'instant,
c'est une force plutôt euh marginale
dans le sens positif. de mot.
Voilà,
on va changer de sujet. On va parler de
du rapport de l'armée sur la propag la
propagande russe.
Un rapport qui a été coécrit par le le
son.
Le rapport n'est pas présenté contre la
propagande russe, c'est un rapport sur
le fake news en général. Non.
Ouais. Ouais. Il parle beaucoup de la
propagande russe dedans.
Oui, il parle beaucoup. Donc ça a été
fait en partie par le centre d'analyse
et de prospective stratégique du K
d'Orset et par
euh un bout par l'armée. Ça vous a fait
quoi de voir un rapport de plus de 200
pages
expliquant que vous étiez revenu aux
anciennes méthodes ?
Nous avons étudié évidemment ce rapport.
Nous avons lu ce rapport.
Euh
ce rapport euh malheureusement s'inscrit
un petit peu dans euh dans dans cette
ligne politique qui existe non
spécialement en France mais dans en
Occident collectif comme nous disons.
Une ligne qui est basée sur le principe
qu'il faut contenir iguer la Russie qui
devient de plus en plus agressif qui
représente en danger et cetera.
Et voilà qu'est-ce que nous avons trouvé
en analysant ce rapport ? On a calculé
combien de fois différents euh mots,
différents pays ont été mentionnés dans
ce rapport de 200 pages comme vous avez
dit. Donc qu'est-ce que nous avons comme
résultat ?
l'État islamique d'Aesh 18 fois les mots
liés avec duisme
et cetera à une dizaine de fois. La
Chine 72 ou 76 fois est mentionné dans
ce rapport. La Russie est mentionnée 426
fois.
Ça nous étonne énormément.
Est-ce que ça veut dire que c'est la
Russie qui représente une menace
principale pour la France et pour le
monde occidental ? Est-ce que ça veut
dire que c'est de la Russie
que le danger vient pour l'existence de
l'Occident, des démocraties
occidentales, des démocraties
européennes ?
C'est une chose absolument euh
inexplicable pour nous. Nous ne pouvons
pas réaliser comment nous sommes arrivés
à ça. Comment en date là
je vous donne des pistes.
Euh oui.
Bon, je vous donne des pistes. Quand à
Saint-Pétersbourg une usine à troll de
4000 m carr offici
qui n'est pas sous l'autorité directe du
gouvernement russe ou pas sous
l'autodirect l'autorité directe de
quelqu'un de du gouvernement et que
cette usine à troll passe de 4000 m² à
12000 m². Et où vous avez pris cette
information ? Qui vous a dit ça ?
Dans le rapport dans le rapport.
Dans le rapport. Oui, mais je veux dire
dans le rapport euh nous revenons
justement au problème d'information.
Donc ça ça les a peut-être un peu
stressé. Donc ils sont peut-être fait
intoxiquer. C'est peut-être pas le cas.
Bon, [soupir]
quand dans ce rapport il marque noir sur
blanc, vous comprenez quand même un
satellite russe s'est approché d'un
satellite français avec des grandes
oreilles.
C'est un sujet qui a été évoqué entre
nos deux pays un moment. Non non euh
c'est en sujet purement technique vrai.
C'est pas vrai.
Euh non, écoutez euh je peux pas vous
donner euh les détails techniques pour
plusieurs raisons. En tout cas, je peux
dire que euh le sujet a été évoqué par
euh euh par
nos partenaires français. En un moment
donné, les explications ont été données
suite à cette demande
et euh pour nous l'affaire a été euh
close. Nous avons donné nos explications
qui était
ça y est
qui était que euh notre satellite ne
représentait aucun danger aux satellites
français ou franco
satellite que pas purement mais peu
importe. En tout cas, euh notre euh
satellite euh euh
ne représentait aucun danger euh pour le
site français.
Vous maîtrisez votre trajectoire, c'est
pas mal.
Non, c'est tout simplement euh on a dit
qu'on n'a pas violé aucune loi
internationale. Tout était inscrit euh
dans les pratiques courantes qui
existent dans l'exploitation actuelle de
l'espace. Ça c'est un peu comme des vols
de l'aviation stratégique russe qui
effectue des vols d'entraînement mais ne
veole pas l'espace territorial
euh des pays euh les métrovs euh de
l'Occident. Il passe près de ses
frontières mais il ne viole jamais. il
n'entre jamais dans l'espace euh de tel
ou tel pays en effectuant les vols dans
l'espace international, en respectant
toutes les règles, toute la toutes les
lois qui existent dans ce domaine-là.
C'est un peu la même histoire. Par
contre, si nous revenons à ce à cette
fabrique de troll,
vous savez le problème c'est que euh il
y a des des espaces, il y a des euh des
organismes des structures où nous
pouvons évoquer ce type de problème.
Parmi ces structures, je peux citer
l'organisation pour la coopération et
euh
OSE pour la
et la sécurité en Europe, OSE qui se
base à Vienne. Il y a un format qui
existe dans dans le cadre de cette
organisation qui permet d'échanger
de tout ce qui concerne les problèmes
informatiques, de tout ce qui concerne
de la sécurité informatique. Il y a des
canaux bélatéraux, il y a des
possibilités d'examiner ces sujets lors
des contacts entre les dirigeants de nos
pays.
Nous voulons évoquer chaque sujet de
façon très concrète et très pratique et
constructive.
Vous voulez nous dire que nous avons une
fabrique des trolls. Venez, présentez
vos preuves et parlons ensemble en ce
qui concerne ce problème là. Nous avons
nous avons nous avons déjà et je peux
vous dire que euh cette discussion entre
euh
cet échange entre les Russes et les
Français sur euh le les problèmes de la
sécurité informatique, il existe et nous
voulons qu'il se développe.
C'est pas de la sécurité informatique
là, ça s'appelle de l'astroturfing.
D'accord.
Là pour nous pour nous nous pour nous
considérons ce problème dans le cadre
d'un grand sujet que nous appelons
sécurité
informatique ou sécurité d'information.
Pour vous donner un exemple, nous
voulons rendre les négociations
concernant ou plutôt les échanges
concernant ce problème. Nous voulons euh
soulever euh cette question à
l'assemblée générale de l'ONU. Nous
voulons évoquer ce sujet dans le cadre
international. Voilà pourquoi
nous allons proposer d'initiatives
sur l'élaboration des règles dans ce
domaine au niveau de l'assemblée
générale de l'ONU. Nous voulons discuter
ça. Nous disons à nos partenaires
américains, vous dites que nous ne
sommes engérés dans vos élections
américaines. Donnenousnous donnez
donnez-nous de preuves. Parlez-nous.
Montrez-nous c'est IP adresse ou je sais
pas quoi. Envoyez-nous des informations,
on va vous donner des réponses. Euh on a
proposé à entreprise de commencer des
d'entamer des consultations
bellatérales.
Nous sommes ouverts, nous sommes prêts à
la discussion. Nous n'avons pas
réussi à convaincre nos partenaires
américains à entamer ce type de
consultation. Nous avons proposé euh à
nos partenaires français de nous
présenter des preuves concretes
d'engérance dans les affaires françaises
pendant l'élection présidentielle. Même
si euh si je ne me trompe pas, la
euh ces accusations euh ont été
prononcées par certains représentants de
la campagne électorale du président
Macron, mais pas par les autorités
françaises à ma connaissance. En tout
cas, jamais on n' pas mis sur la table
l'ordre de contact avec aux différents
niveaux, on n' pas mis sur la table une
liste des questions
adressées à la partie russe. Comment
vous pouvez expliquer tel tel fait ?
Qu'est-ce que vous vouz nous dire sur c
sur telle telle telle ingérence ? jamais
on a été approché par nos partenaires
français malgré notre souhait de
discuter cette affaire de façon
approfondie, de façon constructive dans
l'atmosphère qui existe toujours
dans dans le dialogue franco-russe. Et
nous restons prêts, nous restons ouverts
à discuter tout ça. Et là, vous me
parlez de ce fabrique de troll. Je n'ai
aucune idée. Je n'ai aucune idée si
cette fabrique existe ou non. Je sais
qu'il y a des nous avons évoqué ce sujet
lors de notre compte précédent. Il y a
des hackers indépendant les hackers,
c'est pas pareil. [grognement]
Le le Paul Morera a fait un reportage
dessus où il a été jusqu'à au pied de
l'immeuble où il a été reçu. Bon,
qui ça ?
Paul Morera. Hm hm hm.
On va revenir sur ce sujet après.
Revenons à notre rapport fait par le
Caps et par une partie de l'armée qui a
été présenté dans l'amphithéâtre Foche
avec le ministre de de la défense en
grande pompe. Qu'est-ce qui vous a fait
mal, pas mal ? Qu'est-ce qui vous a
choqué ? Pas choqué ? Non, écoutez, on
était plutôt étonné par cette quantité
par cette cette différence incroyable
entre les citations de certains acteurs
intentionnaux ou non éthétiques et la
Russie. Après avoir fait ces calculs, on
peut faire la conclusion que je répète
que l'ennemi numéro 1 de l'Europe et de
la France, c'est la Russie. Nous ne
pouvons pas accepter cette idée, cette
perception. Euh nous nous
ça ça nous étonne. On
savait, on le savait. [rires]
Euh oui, ça nous étonne énormément parce
que euh ça ne correspond euh pas avec la
réalité à notre avis. Euh la Russie qui
a changé tellement qui n'est présente
euh rien euh de l'Union soviétique de
l'époque en pays avec l'armée de 3 ou 4
millions euh de soldats, avec euh la
surface encore plus beaucoup plus
importante qu'aujourd'hui, avec
l'idéologie puissante qui avait des
partisans partout dans les pays du monde
et en Europe. Avec tous ces instruments,
avec tous ces moyens, je peux imaginer
qu'on représentait un certain danger.
Mais aujourd'hui, quand le pays c'est un
pays démocratique avec des élections,
avec la liberté de la presse, avec
l'opposition système et non système,
avec plusieurs défis, menaces, dingés,
d'éventell, plusieurs de ces menaces
sont communes. Comment ? Ils sont ils se
posent devant la Russie aussi bien que
devant l'Occident. sur la liberté de la
presse. Sur la liberté de la presse,
vous faites souvent tirer les oreilles
par certaines organisations
internationales.
Nous sommes critiqués comme plusieurs
d'autres pays, mais
écoutez, on peut faire mieux peut-être,
mais par rapport à tout ce qu'on avait
euh
avant 91 euh et surtout avec internet,
c'est vraiment ça la liberté.
Telegram. Telegram qui a sauté. Pourquoi
Telegram ? Si je comprends bien,
Telegram fonctionne toujours, mais
Telégramisé
pour euh son désaccorder
avec euh les services spéciaux dans la
lutte contre le problème terroriste.
C'est pas pour surveiller les citoyens
russes
que Service fédéral de sécurité a
demander la coopération. C'est pour
contenir la menace terroriste parce que
nous savons tous ces
outils sont utilisés par les
malfaiteurs, par les terroristes et là
où nous devons coup
par les journalistes qui veulent pas
être écoutés ou par des choses comme ça.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Oui. Par les journalistes
également mais c'était pas contre les
journalistes cit contre les théoristes
quand même. Voilà. Et en plus, on peut
imaginer que Messenger, c'est un seul
outile qui existe et tous ces WhatsApp,
Weber et les autres. Mais
Telegram, c'est un sujet aussi très
technique lié avec ces fameux clés. Euh
je ne suis pas très euh spécialiste dans
ce domaine, mais je peux vous confirmer
quand même que euh Internet, il est
surveillé mais du point de vue euh des
activités inégales euh illégales euh je
sais pas euh euh propagande euh du
racisme, de la xénophobie, de la
violence, euh de l'intolérance
euh par rapport aux différentes ethnies,
confessions, religion et cetera.
pédophilie, euh criminalité organisée,
terrorisme,
internet donne beaucoup de possibilité à
nous tous mais en même temps il
représente certains menac en danger.
Mais je répète, nous voulons avec tous
nos partenaires intentionnaux sans
exception élaborer ensemble des règles
de comportement
dans le domaine en général de de la
sécurité d'information. J'ouvre une
petite parenthèse, une petite diversion
histoire de vous déconcentrer un peu.
Pourquoi Daily Motion est toujours
interdit en Russie ?
Qui ça d
Daily Motion ?
C'est un peu le YouTube français.
Je peux pas vous donner la réponse, je
ne suis pas informé et je ne connais pas
qu'est-ce que c'est euh
Daily Motion.
Daily Motion. Non, hélas,
j'ai honte mais c'est vrai, personne
n'est parfait. Revenons à notre rapport.
Euh
pour vous, le fait que les États-Unis
euh
n'aient pas été euh cité,
que d'autres pays euh n'aient pas été
cités, on parle on parle toujours de la
Russie, la Chine, euh l'axe du mal.
Pourquoi en tant que français, nous on
s'est on s'est posé la question pourquoi
on n' [raclement de gorge] pas eu quand
même une petite partie sur les
États-Unis ? Vous avez eu notre ce même
questionnement ou
vous êtes mieux placé que moi pour
répondre ? Je suis pas français moi.
Mais non, écoutez, voilà, ça c'est ça le
problème.
Nous ne comprenons pas pourquoi
élaborer un tel rapport sans discuter ce
sujet au niveau batéral ou au niveau
multilatéral. Nous sommes pour la pour
le monde multilatéral, pour le monde
pour la politique multilatérale. Nous
sommes absolument d'accord avec le
président Macron qui profite de chaque
son apparition devant euh les décideurs
internationaux ou devant le public
international pour réitérer encore une
fois que la France est partisan de la
multipolarité. Nous aussi, nous sommes
des partisans de multipolarité. Nous
sommes très loin de de l'isolation,
nous sommes très ouverts à la
coopération euh au niveau régional et
international. Regardez ce que nous
faisons. Au lieu de quitter
organisation, nous voulons élargir des
organisations. Nous voulons développer
les contacts entre les différentes euh
euh organisations. Nous sommes partisans
de l'intégration, des intégrations.
Voilà pourquoi nous optons pour la
l'établissement d'un vrai
disons pas partenariat mais pour pour
l'instant d'un contat permanent entre
l'Union européenne et l'organisation
de la coopération euroasiatique que nous
avons créé avec certains de nos
partenaires euh pays membre de de de de
la communauté des états indépendants.
Nous voulons nous nous travaillons
activement avec plusieurs partenaires
dans le cadre de l'organisation de
coopération de Changray. Et il y a
toujours des pays qui veulent entrer
dans cette organisation, devenir
observateurs et membre permanents. Donc
nous sommes absolument ouverts
au contact, à la coopération,
au développement des relations dans tous
les domaines,
y compris dans ce domaine-là. Mais au
lieu de ça, au lieu de ça, nous recevons
un rapport où on nous accuse, où on
présente la Russie, je répète,
comme le premier danger de l' devant qui
qui qui existe devant l'Occident
aujourd'hui. Voilà, je me demande si euh
si les Français partagent cette vision
des choses.
Dans dans ce rapport, on parle beaucoup
des des médias d'influence russe comme
RTS, Spoutnik.
C'est Télécrèelin comme on l'appelle.
Oui, deux chaînes très professionnelles.
Dites-moi s'il vous plaît pour RT-être
pour pour Spoutnik, on émettra quelques
réserves.
Bon, je connais mieux Rach. Rach day euh
c'est [grognement] une grande nouveauté
pour nous. Pour la première fois dans
notre histoire, nous avons créé une
télévision qui doit porter notre vision
des du monde à aux téléspectateurs
internationaux et étrangers. Dites-moi
s'il vous plaît, vous avez une chaîne
magnifique que nous aimons bien et nous
coopérons avec eux. France 24, par
exemple, euh France 4 euh qui parle en
français, en anglais, en arabe, n'est-ce
pas ? En espagnol, non. euh français,
arabe, anglais diffuse ces ses
programmes en trois langues. C'est pour
faire quoi ? C'est pour donner la vision
française du monde. C'est pour donner la
position française, les analyses
français parce que je pense, je présume
que les analyses de Brexit présenté par
France 24 se distingue un petit peu de
la façon de présenter ce qui se passe en
Grande-Bretagne par BBC par exemple.
Donc France 24 existe pour faire savoir
à tous ces téléspectateurs la position
française et c'est normal diffuser sa
vision du monde. La Russie le fait
depuis quelques ans uniquement. On a
créé pour la première fois voilà cette
chaîne Rash Today
2000 2006 et en France on a euh notre
disons section française a été ouverte
l'année dernière je pense. Donc ça
depuis depuis 2 ans peut-être et déjà
cela provoque tant de critiques et tant
de peur mais nous ne faisons que
diffuser notre vision du monde. Est-ce
que c'est un crime ? Est-ce que c'est
une crime ? Moi, je ne le vois pas. On
parle de fake news. Donnez-moi un
exemple. Donc, fake news. Qu'est-ce que
c'est fake news ? Qui décide que c'est
un fake news ? Où est cette frontière
entre fake news et tout simplement la
position ? H
je peux vous dire que en analysant des
articles, des émissions qui parlent de
la Russie dans la presse française, dans
les mass médiia français, nous pouvons
traiter certains de ces sujets, certains
de ces articles comme aussi de comme de
fake news, comme manipulation
d'information.
Euh quand par exemple, on a j'ai
plusieurs exemples quand euh le contenu
euh de l'article ne correspond pas aux
photos qui va avec.
Juste une petite exemple, nous avons
évoqué avec vous les problèmes de
dehomophobie en Russie euh il y a
quelques temps, vous souvenez
et de racisme. Euh et je vous rappelle
que on m'a posé beaucoup de questions
avant le championnat du monde de
football en Russie. Il y avait beaucoup
de peur comment euh les Russes, les
supporteurs russes font traités des
représentants des minorités sexuelles
ethnique.
Vous vous vous savez aujourd'hui que pas
un seul incident lors de tous ces 4
semaines euh de cette grande fête
sportive, pas un seul incident majeur,
pas un seul. C'est à titre de réponse
aux questions qui ont précédé ce
championnat. Et là, je reviens juste un
petit exemple. Imaginez-vous un article
qui concerne une agression euh homophobe
contre un couple dans le 20e
arrondissement de Paris.
et en photo qui représente un jeune
homme et encore quelques gens. C'est un
petit piquet en petit euh comment
dirais-je point de petite petite toute
petite manifestation paraît-il quelque
part en Russie parce que ils ont il
tient un portrait de notre président un
portrait défiguré
avec les mots stop homophobie. Qu'est-ce
que c'est ? Comment traiter comment nous
pouvons traiter ce cascret ?
photo qui pour les gens Oui, il faut il
faut connaître le visage de notre
président mais je pense que tout le
monde le connaît. En photo qui
représente quelqu'un avec un portrait de
Poutine comme je vous ai défiguré avec
un certains très
vexants, j'irais dire et une formation
qui concerne en notre pays en notre cas
une autre capitale qui n'a rien à voir
avec ce portrait. Donc mais les gens qui
lisent euh qui qui qui lisent cet
article ont une compation très claire.
Il y a un lien entre le portrait de
Poutine, stop homophobie et une attaque
contre un couple euh homosexuel dans le
20e arrondissement de Paris. Juste un
petit exemple où euh pendant on on a
constaté par exemple plusieurs cas
pareils quand le photo ne correspond
complètement pas avec le texte de
l'article euh en 2012 quand euh des
manifestations antigouvernementales
étaient très euh comment disais-je
massive en Russie après les élections de
2011, vous souvenez peut-être, on a vu
tant
photo d'une manifestation pro Poutine
une très grande manifestation et le
texte qui parle d'une manifestation
anti-poutine.
Oui, tout simplement c'est
c'est la question de professionnalisme
des gens qui montent cet article, qui
choisissent le photo et cetera. C'est
l'absence absolue d'information et de
connaissance de la langue et des
détails. Mais en même temps, vous
comprenez que nous pouvons traiter euh
cette combinaison d'une photo et d'un
texte comme euh une euh [grognement]
comment dire manipulation informatique
et nous pouvons continuer à ce rapport
quand dans ce rapport quand dans ce
rapport le le
ils analysent le fait pour résumer
trivialement le le ils analysent le fait
que Spoutnik utilise des techniques de
puta clic avec des sujets sur les sur
les seins
sur les extraterrestres, sur les
Illuminati, sur les reptiliens et choses
comme ça.
Comment ça dit ?
Boobs.
Non non non. Technologie. Quelle
technologie ? Pic à pic.
Tu es à clic.
à clic.
Qu'est-ce que c'est put à [grognement]
clic ?
Euh euh pour impater le chalon. Oui oui
oui, je je vois je vois maintenant. Je
vois qu'est-ce que c'est. Oui, écoutez,
c'est pour attirer euh le public pour
les pour les nouvelles de ce type genre
de ce genre-là. Bah, écoutez, mais c'est
la politique
de cette chaîne-là.
Je peux pas commenter ça, je sais pas
comment ça fonctionne.
Est-ce que vous pouvez faire une un
parallèle avec la la Yellow Presse
anglaise ?
Peut-être, peut-être, peut-être, mais
malheureusement je sais que ce problème,
je comprends de quoi vous parlez. Je
rencontre le même type de de sujet. Je
peux le rencontrer
en visitant n'importe quel euh site des
nouvelles de d'une grande journale,
d'une radiostation et cetera. Ça ça
existe, ça existe mais je sais pas
comment commenter ça. Peut-être
qu'est-ce que vous n'aimez pas dans
cette pratique là ? dites-moi,
nous nous on n'est pas là pour aimer ou
pas aimer. On constate, c'est tout le on
a lu le rapport de 214 pages,
on a pris 4 heures pour l'étudier
euh euh du moins le lire le lire
et ce moment a été mentionné euh
ouais sur la stratégie un peu putaclique
clairement
putaclic et euh nous on a un regard on
écoutez quand même je vous dis euh
franchement euh comme comme elle a été
convenue euh je ne connais pas très bien
ce sujet de cette put à clic
est-ce que le gouvernement russe Est-ce
que le gouvernement russe a un regard
sur ces deux médias ? Est-ce que Est-ce
sur ces deux médias ?
Est-ce que vous donnez des ordres à
Spoutnik et ou à Rocher Today un chin
? Est-ce que la rédaction
de votre grand journal donne des
instructions à ces journalistes ?
Peut-être pas chaque jour, mais est-ce
qu'il y a une ligne politique respectée
par tel ou tel journal ? Je pense que
oui
en France
oui en France
on a Libération on a le F
non je veux pas citer je veux pas citer
les journaux mais vous savez qu'il y a
des journaux qui sont plutôt qui
appartient plutôt à l'aile gauche du
monde politique les autres plutôt à
l'aile droite. Je pense qu'il y a une
politique de la rédaction n'est-ce pas
et les journalistes font leur choix
s'ils travaillent dans cette dans ce
journal il respecte
tel ou tel
comment dirais-je conception politique
de ce journal. Ils respectent certains
euh instructions euh de leur rédacteur
en chef. Je pense que comptenu que
Rachet c'est une chaîne d'État financée
par l'État, évidemment elle existe pour
donner la vie de l'État russe. Mais
je soutiens toujours l'idée que c'est
normal, ce n'est pas un crime parce que
l'État russe a le droit de voir des
instruments, des léviers pour faire
savoir ce qu'il pensent ou plutôt ce que
la Russie pense sur tel ou tel sujet
international ou national
comme France 24 et d'autres.
Voilà.
Euh
on va continuer sur ce rapport-là. vers
la fin du rapport, il il préconise euh
une le la création d'un organisme
international qui dicterait les règles
de la presse, un peu comme la charte de
Munique
avec la participation de la Russie ou
non.
Est-ce que vous êtes prêt à participer ?
Euh alors, je crois que vous avez déjà
signé la Charte de Munich.
Évidemment, évidemment. Nous sommes
évidemment nous sommes prêts, comme je
vous ai dit, nous sommes ouverts à tout
type de dialogue dans tout le domaine, y
compris dans ce domaineel. Euh et euh si
je vois bien euh il y a quelques temps à
Paris, il y avait déjà quelques réunions
euh concernant l'élaboration
des règles de jeu dans le domaine des
masses médiia et les représentants
russes ont été présents. Donc euh
j'espère que la Russie soit invitée sera
invitée à prendre part dans les travaux
de euh de de cette de ce nouveau
éventuel organisme. Et croyez-moi, nous
avons quoi à dire.
Alors, question d'internet. Qu'est-ce
qu'un ambassadeur russe peut pense du
fait que la DGSI travaille avec Palantir
financé par la CIA ?
Palentir.
Précisez-moi. Palentir. Qu'est-ce que
c'est ?
Alors, Palentir, c'est
quelque chose qui agrège énormément de
data pour faire remonter soit de la
prospective, soit de la formation.
D'accord. Mais non, en tout cas, je peux
répondre très facilement. Euh, d'abord,
je ne suis pas ambassadeur, je suis
ministre conseiller de l'ambassade.
Deuxièmement, euh nous ne commentons pas
les activités des services spéciaux. Ça
c'est pas notre affaire. Nous
travaillons de façon tout à fait euh
légitime. Nous représentons euh notre
État en France ou ailleurs et les
services spéciaux, ils se contactent. Ça
c'est une chose tout à fait différente.
Donc euh en plus euh je ne suis pas très
bien informé de cette coopération
concrète et euh euh
je peux vous je peux vous dire en tout
cas que euh
tous les services spéciaux dans le monde
se coopèrent et se parlent.
Voonà en fait la question on disait on
va on va la prendre entre les lignes.
Les Français
coopère massivement avec les services
américains.
Les Français quand vous dites les
Français, vous parlez des servic des
structures d'état des structures d'état.
Je ne pense pas que la France coopère
aussi profondément avec les services
russes.
Bon, écoutez, euh ben c'est c'est
normal, euh la Russie euh ne fait pas
partie de l'européenne.
Euh la France et les États-Unis, ce sont
des alliés très proches. Et euh
qu'est-ce que vous étonnooprent,
c'est normal. En tout cas, je peux vous
je peux vous dire que les services
spéciaux russes coopèrent avec les
services spéciaux américains et
coopèrent avec les services spéciaux
français. C'est normal, c'est surtout
dans le monde actuel avec le problème de
terrorisme.
Donc la suite, c'est l'Union européenne
massivement
pied point li avec les États-Unis.
Est-ce que la la vraie question c'est
est-ce que la Russie se sent de plus en
plus acculée
par ce qu'elle pourrait considérer comme
une force béliqueuse à ses frontières ?
Mais là euh
rien euh le problème c'est que rien n'a
changé après la disparition de l'Union
soviétique. Ça c'est ça c'est le
problème.
Ça concerne les services spéciaux euh
occidentaux, ça concerne euh euh les
relations dans le domaine militaire et
en général ça concerne le système de
sécurité globale.
après
l'effondrement de l'Union soviétique,
après l'effondrement de du bloc de
Varsovie, la situation sécuritaire en
Europe a changé de façon absolument
spectaculaire.
Le monde a changé en général et le
système de sécurité n'a pas beaucoup
évolué. Au contraire, il a évocué et il
a évolué. Mais dans quel sens ?
Aujourd'hui, nous avons le temps devant
nos frontières. Nous avons la frontière
commune avec les pays de le temps. Nous
avons des contangens importants euh des
pays de l'OTAN à proximité de nos
frontières. Nous avons un système global
de la défense antimissile qui est en
train d'être construit par les
Américains et les Européens système de
leon. Donc voilà ce que nous avons
devant nous. Nous avons des bases
américaines partout un petit peu dans le
monde autour de nos frontières. Nous
avons des bases américaines toujours en
Corée, au Japon, dans l'Opacifique.
Nous avons des bases militaires
américaines en Afghanistan, en Irak.
Nous avons la présence américaine en
Syrie, nous avons la présence américaine
en Afrique. Euh voilà, donc le monde a
changé et le système de sécurité, y
compris en Europe, n'a pas évolué du
tout, ce que ne peut que provoquer notre
euh chagrin et notre volonté.
de changer la situation. Voilà pourquoi
nous avons proposé à un moment donné et
il y a quelques ans euh nous avons
proposé à signer
une nouvelle traité sur la sécurité en
Europe. Une traité qui devrait prendre
en compte les changements qui ont euh
qui ont eu lieu après le fondement de
l'Union soviétique et après la le
changement complet de de la situation
géostratégique dans le monde.
Pour l'instant, pas de réponse.
Qui vous voyez pour succéder à Vladimir
Poutine ?
Il est trop tôt euh de traiter ce sujet
parce que président Poutine a devant lui
5 ans de travail. Je je pense que les
hommes politiques,
les personnalités concrètes euh
viendront au fur et à mesure de
l'approche de
de des prochaines élections
présidentielles. Pour l'instant, il
travaille, il ne pense pas à un
successeur. Et en tout chose, vous avez
vu ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
semaines en Russie euh lors des
élections régionales.
Euh quatre candidats qui représentaient
le parti au pouvoir, la Russie unifié
ont perdu ou plutôt deux ont perdu, un
aoncé et 4e a été remplacé. Il y aura un
autre la 2e 2e tour euh des élections
des gouverneurs de de la région de Vlad.
Donc ce que veut dire que euh nous avons
une vraie vie politique. Euh il y a des
forces d'opposition, il y a des gens qui
arrivent, il y a des de nouvelles
personnalités euh de nouvelles euh de
nouveau en politique. Euh donc euh on va
voir demain euh ce que ce que va nous
attendre vers [raclement de gorge]
la fin du mandat de président Poutine.
Est-ce que les Russes s'inquiètent de la
l'après-Poutine ? Parce que d'après du
moins c'est purement
c'est une vision de l'esprit. Tous les
Russes avec qui j'ai pu discuter en
Russie pris de c de là s'inquièteent de
l'après-Poutine
parce que pour eux Poutine
a assaigné le pays et il s'inquiète de
revoir quelqu'un de corrompu derrière ou
de manipuler par le par des personnes
extérieures, des ingérences de de pays
extérieurs. Non, moi je j'enregistre pas
cette inquiétude
euh pour l'instant parce que euh il y a
encore 5 ans devant nous.
Mais on va voir euh en tout cas euh il y
a une grande équipe autour de Poutine.
Il y a des gens qui euh euh qui ont
manifesté leur euh grande capacité de
travailler et d'avoir des résultats. On
va voir.
C'est tout ce que je peux vous dire pour
l'instant. Moi, je ne veux pas. Je pour
l'instant je ne vois je ne vois aucune
inquietude majeure ou préoccupation.
La vie est compliquée. Nous vivons
aujourd'hui. Nous avons des tâches à
exécuter maintenant. Nous avons des
problèmes à traiter aujourd'hui et
demain. Et ce que nous attend
après-demain, on va réfléchir comme
Scarlet Tohara disait. Je vais en penser
demain.
La procrastination, c'est ça ?
Alors, question d'internet, on peut se
moquer de Poutine en Russie ? Point
d'interrogation.
Oui.
Alors, autre question d'Internet. Grâce
aux sanctions de la Russie, Grâce aux
sanctions, la Russie devient leader
mondial des exportations de céréales. La
Russie cherche-t-elle à devenir autonome
d'un point de vue alimentaire ?
Évidemment euh c'est en euh en principe
je pense que chaque pays euh le souhait
être absolument indépendant dépend de de
des produits alimentaires, mais c'est
difficile euh et euh euh ça dépend euh
euh de l'étendue de votre pays, euh ça
dépend du climat et cetera, mais les
sanctions nous ont bien démontré que
il est préférable quand même, il est
préférable euh d'être autonome.
Mais le moment n'est pas venu. Nous
avons beaucoup progressé du point de vue
de la production euh agroalémentaire.
Euh le secteur de l'agriculture était le
secteur le plus qui a connu plus de
succès après l'introduction des
sanctions et c'est normal parce que ils
étaient obligés de travailler plus, de
développer leur leur production et et
cetera. Euh mais je peux pas vous dire
que c'est en idée fixe, mais on
travaille on travaille beaucoup dans le
domaine de l'agriculture pour produire
plus, pour exporter, vous avez raison.
Euh je me souviens très bien des années
euh soviétiques là où la question des
céréales, la question de pain, c'est une
question cruciale parce queon était
obligé parfois d'acheter euh du blé en
Argentine, au Canada, aux États-Unis.
Aujourd'hui, nous exportons notre blé.
Nous nous sommes devenus un expectateur
parmi les premiers ou peut-être numéro
1. C'est génial, c'est très bien, nous
sommes très contents. Mais il faut
produire plus de viande. Je sais que on
a beaucoup progressé avec la production
de de
du voulail,
mais il y a d'autres domaines où on peut
faire mieux. La population est grande,
145 euh 145
euh euh millions d'habitants. Euh nous
exportons une partie des légumes et des
fruits. Euh mais voilà, je répète,
c'est souhait, c'est souhait d'être
indépendant, même si pour l'instant nous
sommes assez loin de ça.
Alors, autre question internet que je
vais vous lire tel quel. Y a-t-il
aujourd'hui des écrivains de la trompe
de Tolstoy, Dostovski, Bougakov ? Et
sinon, est-ce à cause du soviétisme ou
du libéralisme nationaliste poutinien ou
des deux ?
Oui. Euh, je me demande si aujourd'hui
en France, il y a des écrivains comme
Molière, euh, je sais pas, Alexandre
Duma ou Stendal, c'est une bonne
question. Euh, prenez la musique
classique par exemple. Euh, est-ce que
bon la musique classique moderne existe
? Mais pour moi, par exemple, moi je
suis resté dans le 17e 18e siècle avec
les grands comme Bethoven, euh Mozart,
Bac et cetera. Donc c'est une question
de goût. Euh la litiéature rue, c'est
très riche. Euh il y a plusieurs
plusieurs écrivants. À mon avis pour
l'instant
notre terre n'a pas donné des écrivants
de ce niveau-là comme Dsto et
Dostoyevski.
Mais peut-être il est petit et il
grandit, il lit ses grands auteurs et il
va devenir comme tel dans quelques ans.
Mais je répète la choix des auteurs est
très riche. Euh vous pouvez choisir et
la liberté absolue. Si avant il faut
être membre
euh de l'organisation des écrivants de
l'Union soviétique, aujourd'hui c'est la
liberté de penser absolue. Vous pouvez
éditer votre publier votre ouvrage à
n'importe quel moment. personne ne peut
pas vous empêcher de le faire si vous
respectez la législation et s'il n'y a
pas de propagande
euh je sais pas de de de néonazisme ou
de xénophobie agressive et pour ça il y
a des organs spécials qui évidemment
veillent. Euh mais à part ça, si vous
respectez la loi, vous êtes absolument
libre dans vos pensées, dans vos
activités littéraires. Euh vous pouvez
faire n'importe quoi. Il y a des auteurs
très intéressants, mais je répète, dire
que nous avons aujourd'hui Anolstoy ou
en Dostoyevski vivant euh
non moi je ne vois pas. Parlons un peu
de l'affaire scripale, les derniers
rebondissements.
Euh, vous avez déjà fait un peu de
tourisme dans la cathédrale de Salzbury
?
Non, non, j'adore les cathédrales mais
pour l'instant je m'occupe de la France.
L'interview qui a été faite par RT
des des deux recherchés
ressortissant russes.
Ouais.
Ça vous a fait penser à quoi ?
Deux types très bizarres.
Euh tout ça c'est une histoire
absolument étonnante. Euh mais vous
savez que euh quand les Britanniques ont
publié pour la première fois leurs
photos, ils ont dit tout de suite que
les noms Highly likely sont faux. Mais
voilà, euh on nous a présenté ces deux
euh mecs très bizarres, très étranges.
Euh non, il y a il y a beaucoup de
questions. Il y a toujours beaucoup de
questions. Mais ce que je peux vous dire
encore une fois, malgré des dizaines de
nos offres au partenaires britanniques
de parler et d'évoquer les sujets en
regardant les yeux dans les yeux, nous
n'avons reçu aucune réponse, soit des
réponses négatives. Donc nous constatons
toujours l'absence de la volonté de
travailler ensemble soit au niveau
bilatéral soit au niveau multilatéral à
la où se trouve le siège de
l'organisation pour l'interdiction pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques. Donc
aucune volonté de de coopérer, de
travailler. Toujours des accusations qui
ont été faites quelques jours après
l'incident. toujours des des
allégations, des nouveaux euh de nouveau
de nouvelles informations sans aucune
précision, sans aucune preuve. Nous
restons toujours dans dans le même au
même niveau euh de l'investigation.
Nous n'avons pas d'épreuves, nous
n'avons pas de faits, nous n'avons pas
des réponses aux centaines de nos
questions, mais il y a ces deux mecs qui
sont très bizarres.
Pourquoi bizarres ?
Rien bizarre parce que euh
dans la même chambre, c'est ça ?
Comment ?
Parce qu'ils dorment dans la même
chambre. Non non parce que il vient
en Grande-Bretagne pour quelques jours
pour aller à Salby,
pour aller deux fois là-bas pour
revenir. Mais même si c'est bizarre,
cela ne va pas dire que ce sont deux
officiers des services spéciaux russes
qui ont qui ont empoisonné Scripal avec
agent neutrotoxique d'une force
incroyable
avec en scripal vivant avec sa fille en
pleine forme et avec l'absence de
quelconque contact entre nos
collaborateurs consolaires, entre nos
diplomates et ces deux ressortissants
russes. Parce que si le prénom Scripa,
lui il est à la fois euh citoyen de la
Grande-Bretagne ou plutôt sujet de sa
majesté.
Julia Scripal, sa fille, c'est une
citoyenne russe.
Selon tous les documents qui existent,
plutôt selon la convention de Vienne sur
les affaires sur les relations
consolaires, notre consul de la
contacter même en présence de d'une
dizaine de policiers britanniques armés
s'ils ont peur qu'il va l'empoisonner
encore une fois. Mais ce contact est
nécessaire pour voir dans quel état elle
est. Qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit ?
Où il se trouve ? Ben disons où il se
trouve plutôt comment elle se sent
aujourd'hui
d'aller mieux. Voilà, en tout cas on n'
pas reçu de réponse. Nous n'avons pas
d'accès à Yuli Scripal et ça c'est une
des un des problèmes et surtout
les Britanniques ne veulent pas coopérer
au sens au sein de sur la site de de
l'organisation à la ils ne veulent pas
coopérer au niveau bilatéral. il envoie
de nouvelles et de nouvelles accusations
et
allégations. Donc
c'est c'est toujours une impasse.
Alors vous vous rappelez dans notre
dernière interview, vous nous faisiez
une proposition d'inviter vos vos
collègues d'autres ambassades.
Autre proposition.
Oui oui mais vous faites la même
proposition que nous.
Alors, on a toujours pas de de réponse
des États-Unis, de l'ambassade des
États-Unis pour venir parler avec vous
et l'ambassade de Suède, c'est c'est un
petit peu débiné.
H [soupir]
euh vous réétirez votre proposition de
discuter avec eux. toujours toujours
nous sommes toujours disponibles, nous
sommes toujours ouverts parce que je
pense qu'un échange respectueux même
j'imagine que euh mes propos mes
positions ne seront pas bien accueilles
par mes collègues parce qu'ils ont leurs
propres instructions, leurs propres
positions. Mais en tout cas, cet
échange, pourquoi pas ? Non non, je je
répète que euh c'est le même principe de
notre politique étrangère. Nous sommes
toujours ouverts et prêts à parler, à
dialoguer euh avec
nos collègues européens, avec nos
collègues asiatiques ou arabes ou ou
n'importe qui parce que nous sommes
profondément convaincus que ce le
dialogue peuvent peut nous aider à
tourner la page et peut nous permettre
de trouver des solutions en multiples
problèmes qui existent.
Vous avez des idées pour nous aider à
les faire venir ? Ah non, non, moi je je
peux pas m'impliquer dans cette
affaire-là. Je suis prêt. Euh je suis
disponible.
Euh voilà et euh mais c'est à vous de
euh si sinon euh ils vont traiter ça
comme une provocation. Je sais pas, tout
peut arriver.
Euh je pense qu'on a fait le tour. Vous
avez des sujets à aborder avec nous ?
Euh je suis largement satisfait par vrai
par tous les par disons par la choix des
sujets qui ont été discutés.
Ben je sais pas, je jette un coup d'œil
sur mes montres. Ça fait presque 2h.
Ouais. Alors, on arrive à la fin
[grognement] et à la fin, on nous donne
toujours une bouteille à la mer, un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
H [raclement de gorge]
oui, là je suis mieux préparé que la
foie précédente. Euh donc non, vraiment
aujourd'hui euh
il y a une nouvelle
euh comment hausse d'intérêt à l'égard
de la Russie. Euh et euh je propose h à
nos jeunes à nos jeunes amis français et
autres euh de ne pas avoir peur de la
Russie,
de ne pas écouter uniquement euh
les mass médias et euh les propos des
gens qui se disent spécialistes sur les
questions russes. Je leur propose tout
simplement de venir en Russie.
de commencer peut-être parler à ceux qui
ont visité déjà euh notre pays et les
Français cette année étaient très
nombreux qui sont venus pour qui sont
venus chez nous pour supporter votre
superbe équipe nationale qui a remporté
par la deuxème fois euh le titre de
champion du monde et nous sommes très
heureux, nous les Russes, nous sommes
très heureux que les Français ont gagné
sur le sol russe en Russie chez nous.
Euh je connais pas les chiffres mais je
pense que une bonne dizaine de milliers
et même plus de français sont venus en
Russie ont découvert non non uniquement
comme d'habitude Moscou et
Saint-Pétersbourg mais aussi d'autres
villes russes en commençant par Casanne
où l'équipe nationale française a
commencé son aventure vers la première
place vers les médailles
chaudron du Tatarstan
comment
c'est le chaudron du Tatarstan
Oui tout à fait donc euh j'appelle tous
les jeunes français euh de laisser de
côté tous ces peurs et tous ces rumeurs,
de unir chez nous, de regarder, de
rencontrer leur euh leur euh comment
dirais-je euh leurs frères et sœurs
russes euh de découvrir notre pays qui
n'est pas un pays de cocagne, un pays
qui qui parfois qui reste toujours
difficile à vivre dans certaines
régions, qui a qui connaît beaucoup de
problèmes mais qui est peuplé par des
gens euh magnifique
euh euh qui est caractérisé par son
hospitalité surtout par rapport aux
étrangers à l'encontre des étrangers et
ils ont bien reconnu à présent plus
quand ils sont français
quand ils sont français parce que on
aime beaucoup la France et on aime
beaucoup les Français. Donc venez
comparer euh certaines choses peut-être
euh ne va vous pas plaire. Euh peut-être
les autres choses vont vous fasciner,
mais il faut venir, c'est mieux de venir
que écouter ou regarder émission qui, je
vous assure ne donne pas l'impression
complète euh des choses. Il faut
toujours euh et là je reviens déjà à
l'idée que j'ai déjà évoqué plusieurs
fois, il faut toujours comparer des
différentes types d'informations. Voilà
pourquoi il faut regarder Rash Today,
il faut regarder France 24 et d'autres
chaînes qui il faut regarder BBC
et CNN et après vous allez faire votre
choix, vous allez analyser toutes ces
informations et je répète la Russie ne
peut pas être ennemi de la France ou de
l'Europe. La Russie fait partie de
l'espace européenne, de l'espace de la
de cette grande espace euroasiatique qui
commence à les Sabones et se termine
à niveau stock. L'espace
de l'Atlantique à l'ural comme disait le
général des Guls euh aujourd'hui nous
disons de les Sabonnes jusqu'à
Bolivostock pour démontrer qu'elle est
grande notre continent. La Russie euh
n'est pas un ennemi. La Russie c'est un
ami. La Russie c'est un pays qui est lié
avec la France et avec l'Europe euh
par des multiples liens qui existent
depuis des millénaires, depuis un
millénaire au minimum. Donc voilà, même
si nous avons des divergences, même si
nous avons des intérêts qui ne
correspond qui ne coincident pas
toujours, nous ne sommes pas des
ennemis. Nous pouvons travailler,
coopérer ensemble dans l'intérêt de nos
peuples, dans l'intérêt de l'humanité
globalement dit.
On va déjà commencer par passer nos
vacances en Russie. Artem Studenikov,
merci.
Merci. Merci beaucoup.